yep sensible that is nice actually that
is
kind of the maximum that white can hope
for just keeping maximum control there
and uh okay black's queen looking for a
new avenue of attack but it's not
nothing no threat though nothing and now
i would and now i just think whites will
just move the bishop out of the way
queen is going to come and give check on
the bottom row and it's just game over
there's nothing to do we're about to see
farouzia in the semi-finals white is
simply a bishop up for nothing and white
is the one actually getting to the black
king first yeah as you mentioned ivanka
white's queen coming up to the top
giving check there's actually no
sensible way to prevent that other than
retreating the black queen but if you
start retreating and if you're a piece
down
it's going to end a disaster anyway wow
18 eighteen-year-old olly reservoirs
against maybe the best player throughout
the tour
and wesley so has he resigned yeah
it looks like it looks that way from
both players cameras i think wesley so
has resigned it's a hopeless position
anyway so it would make sense but
for rooza he's not celebrating yet yeah
so we can't celebrate um we can't kind
of take that result into account either
yet
okay it looks that way it must have
happened that way yeah actually with no
time either i do think we have a winner
and i think it's 18 year old ali reza
rouzia wesley so he looks a little bit
resigned faruzia has his camera stopped
i would love to see a celebration from
the 18